[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
wenn Menschen eine Seele hätten
dann hätte ich das gesehen bei den
ganzen Frauen die ich tot gemacht habe
aber da war nie was nur Hering haben
meine Seele
die heutige Folge ist definitiv ein Fall
für eine triggerwarnung wir sprechen
über eine wahnsinnig brutale Mordserie
im Deutschland der Nachkriegszeit es
geht um Mord und Vergewaltigung und ein
unfassbares Maß an Menschenverachtung
wie man schon an dem Zitat merkt dass er
eben gehört habt aber erstmal hallo wir
sind Marco Kasimir und Toni Haier und
das ist Tatort Deutschland hi Mirko
hallo Toni und herzlich willkommen liebe
Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer ja und gleich
mal entschuldigung das war wirklich sehr
schwerer Einstieg aber ich sag mal so
die ganze Folge wird leider ziemlich
heftig und da dachte ich mir springen
wir am besten gleich ins kalte Wasser zu
den Hering oder was weil die im
Gegensatz zu Menschen offenbar
insbesondere Frauen wenigstens eine
Seele haben naja es ist ich hoffe mal es
ist klar geworden dass das ein Zitat war
und natürlich kein Statement von mir ja
der Satz stammt nämlich von Rudolf Pfeil
und der besser bekannt als Der Totmacher
aber Der Totmacher das war doch
eigentlich ein Film ja stimmt mit Götz
George und in diesem Film geht es um den
Massenmörder Fritz Hamann den hatten wir
hier auch schon sozusagen als Gast ja
stimmt aber das war eben nur der Titel
des Films Haman der zwischen 1918 und
19/24 zwei Dutzend Jungen und junge
Männer auf sehr bestialische Weise
ermordete der hatte seine Zeit alle
möglichen Beinamen unter anderem der
Vampir der Werwolf der schlechter oder
der Kannibale und Rudolf Pleil der war
sozusagen der original Totmacher ich
weiß diese Betätigung ist schrecklich
aber den Namen den hat er sich ja
immerhin selbst gegeben übrigens mit
Bezug auf Harman denn in seinen Memoiren
behauptet er er habe insgesamt 25
Menschen ermordet einen mehr als Hamann
und ihm Gebühren die Bezeichnung größter
Totmacher
also Konkurrenz und Ehrgeiz finde ich
hier wirklich fehl am Platz ja das ist
sehr vorsichtig ausgedrückt vermutlich
hat Pleil übertrieben als er das
behauptete aber er war ein Massenmörder
ein Serienkiller und reiht sich damit
nahtlos ein in die Riege der grausamsten
Verbrecher der deutschen
Kriminalgeschichte ja und wie man schon
aus dem heringszitat entnehmen kann ist
der eiskalt und zutiefst
menschenverachtend die Geschichte des
todmachers hat so viele bizarre Facetten
dass wir sie euch in zwei Teilen
erzählen und Mirko jetzt mal Butter bei
die Heringe wer war Rudolf Pleil Rudolf
Pleil wird am 7 juli 1924 in kühberg
einem Dorf im Erzgebirge nahe der Grenze
zur damaligen Tschechoslowakei geboren
sein Vater ist Arbeiter und Kommunist
außerdem ein gewalttätiger Alkoholiker
der seine Frau verprügelt
nach der Macht Ergreifung der Nazis wird
der kurzzeitig verhaftet aber weil er
Kommunist ist nicht weil er seine Frau
schlägt das war damals nichts womit sich
die Polizei befasst hätte als er frei
kommt siedelt die Familie in einen
benachbartes tschechisches Dorf über
schon kurz danach muss der gerade einmal
neunjährige die arbeitslosen Eltern
unterstützen indem er Schokolade über
die Grenze schmuggelt 1939 mit 15 Jahren
verlässt er sein Zuhause und beginnt
eine fleischerlehre die er nach kurzer
Zeit wieder abbricht stattdessen
arbeitet er als Schiffsjunge auf
Frachtkähnen auf der Elbe und der oder
nebenher verdient er ein bisschen Geld
indem er etwas von der Ladung abzweigt
und an Land verkauft Oder und Elbe
werden ihm schnell zu eng er will aufs
Meer und in die große weite Welt
und schon im Sommer 1939 kurz war
Ausbruch des Zweiten Weltkrieges heuert
er auf einem Handelsschiff an dass nach
Südamerika fährt Pleil nennt die
folgenden Jahre später seine große Zeit
er fährt als Decks junge messewart und
tellerwäsche auf Handelsschiffen und
Truppentransporter nach Norwegen Italien
und Frankreich
Pleil liebt das wechselhafte das
Abenteuer die Kameradschaft an Bord die
Bordelle in den Hafenstädten obwohl er
die Bordelle wohl eher aufsucht weil es
von ihm erwartet wird denn wirkliche
Befriedigung verschaffen ihm die Besuche
nicht
das wichtigste aber wird der Schnaps der
junge Mann wird zum heftigen Trinker
seine Gaunereien gehen in dieser Zeit
weiter unter anderem verkauft er Decken
und Wäsche aus wehrmachtsbeständen an
Prostituierte dabei wird er erwischt und
von einem marinefeld Gericht zu einem
Jahr Jugendhaft verurteilt das sitzt der
ab und kommt danach als kohletrimmer
zurück zur Marine und ins Mittelmeer den
Job den musste ich übrigens Nachschlagen
trim heißt hier so viel wie schleppen
bei der Marine läuft es inzwischen
ziemlich schlecht für die deutschen
Pleil wird mehrmals aus dem Meer
gefischt nach dem Bomben der Alliierten
sein Schiff versenkt haben
1943 überlebt er sogar einen
Flugzeugabsturz was für die meisten
Menschen eine Abfolge von unfassbaren
Schrecken und Traumata wäre das ist für
play der Höhepunkt seines Lebens
das Flugzeug mit dem er abstürzt sollte
ihn übrigens in ein Lazarett in
Deutschland bringen zur wie es heißt
nervenärztlichen Beobachtung denn nach
einem Trinkgelage erlitt Pleil einen
epileptischen Anfall auch seine
Schwester leidet ein Epilepsie als 1940
das sogenannte gesetzt zur Verhütung
erbkranken Nachwuchses in Kraft tritt
wird sie zwangsterilisiert an der Stelle
vielleicht ganz kurz dass dieses Gesetz
und solche Maßnahmen unmenschlich sind
das ist ganz klar davon abgesehen gibt
es zwar genetische Faktoren die eine
Epilepsie begünstigen aber eine direkte
vererbarkeit ist nur bei einigen
seltenen Formen der Krankheit gegeben
Patienten die an Epilepsie Lippen
gehörten übrigens auch zu den ersten die
von den Nazis vergast wurden aber das
ist ein ganz anderes Verbrechen als auch
bei ihm Epilepsie diagnostiziert wird
erklärt man ihn für dienstuntauglich
widerwillig nimmt er eine Stelle als in
einer erzgebirgischen Kleinstadt an die
das Arbeitsamt ihm zuweist er hat in
dieser Zeit eine Beziehung zu einer
jungen Frau und wird sogar Vater für
seine Freundin ich sage das jetzt ganz
bewusst so wird diese Beziehung bald zur
Hölle Sex allein
befriedigt-vergewaltigt die Frau beißt
sie wirkt sie wird immer grausamer als
sie sich endlich trennen gibt sie das
Kind in die Pflege von Kleids Schwester
die aufgrund Sterilisation keine eigenen
Kinder mehr haben kann als bei Rudolf
Pleil wiederholt epileptische Anfälle
auftreten soll er ebenfalls Zwang
sterilisiert werden aber er entgeht der
Operation weil nur wenige Tage vor dem
geplanten Eingriff das Krankenhaus in
Chemnitz bei einem Bombenangriff
zerstört wird
Werbung Stefan ja ich weiß ja dass du
hin und wieder eine kleine Sportwette
abschließt richtig ja eine kleine ich
muss sagen das mache ich tatsächlich
ganz gerne vor allem wenn es besonders
spannende Spiele gibt bei denen es um
was geht dann kennst du ja sicherlich
Neo Bett oder na klar das ist doch der
Sportwettenanbieter bei dem Laura
Wontorra Markenbotschafterin ist genau
den Spot mit ihr habe ich auch schon mal
im Fernsehen gesehen ach und wusstest du
Anna das neo-bett einer der ersten
weltanbieter mit deutscher Lizenz ist
die wurde vor kurzem erst wieder um 5
Jahre verlängert nein aber jetzt weiß
ich tja und ich habe sogar was für dich
und für euch wenn ihr Neo Bett auch
besser kennenlernen wollt und zwar 10 €
wird Guthaben für Neukunden mit dem Code
Podcast ziehen als Zahl auf neo-bett.de
ich wiederhole mit dem Code Podcast 10
als Zahl auf Neo bett.de also einfach
bei der Registrierung auf neobett.de den
Code Podcast 10 eingeben zehn als Zahl
und sofort landen zehn Euro ohne
Einzahlung auf dem bettkonto Leopard
from musst du sein Konditionen gelten
Spiel Teilnahme ab 18 glücksspiel kann
süchtig machen offiziell lizenzierter
wettpartner white listet Hilfe unter
bzga.de
Werbung Ende
mai 1945 der Zweite Weltkrieg ist vorbei
die letzten Kriegsmonate hat Pleil als
Koch in einem Kriegsgefangenenlager
zugebracht wo er seine ganz eigene und
sehr spezielle Diät entwickelt er tötet
Katzen mit der bloßen Faust dann ist er
sie und das bereitet ihm ein
unerklärbares Lustgefühl
Roman also mal ganz ehrlich wenn ein
Mensch ein Tier so behandelt und wenn es
ihm offenbar Lust bereitet Katzen mit
der bloßen Faust zu töten dann ja da
müssten eigentlich alle Alarmglocken
schrillen denn das sind ja irgendwie
eindeutige Warnsignale für einen
wirklich riesiges Gewaltpotenzial ja bei
Play liegst Du damit verdammt richtig
das wird sich auch bald zeigen sein
Heimatdorf wird von der Roten Armee
besetzt und Pleil schließt sich eine
Arbeiter Miliz an die als eine Art
Hilfspolizei für die besatzerfundiert
einer der Einsätze muss ihm wirklich
genug tun bereitet haben er verhaftet
den Amtsarzt der ihn zwang sterilisieren
lassen wollte naja ich sag mal so das
kann man sogar noch nachvollziehen ganz
im Gegensatz zu anderen Vorfällen
während seiner Zeit bei der Arbeiter
Miliz die für seinen weiteren Weg eine
große Rolle spielen werden
seinen Weg vom katzenkiller zum
Serienmörder
eines Tages trifft er auf Plünderer und
schießt versehentlich einen sowjetischen
Soldaten an es ist dabei nicht ganz klar
ob der Soldat selbst einer der Plünderer
war jedenfalls als Rudolf Pley versucht
die blutende Wunde zu verbinden erlebt
er es wieder dieses
unerklärbare Lustgefühl Pleil heiratet
eine junge Frau die von ihm schwanger
geworden ist auch sie erleidet
schreckliche Gewalt wird zum Opfer von
pleisterismus der immer deutlicher wird
der ihn immer weiter treibt zu noch
größerer Grausamkeit
möglicherweise begeht er schon bald
danach im Jahr 1945 seine ersten Morde
diese werden aber nie nachgewiesen er
erzählt davon in seinen Memoiren aber
wahrscheinlich hat er sie nur erfunden
um auf die 25 Opfer zu kommen die er
braucht um sich als größter Totmacher zu
rühmen
sicher ist aber dass der Beginn jungen
Frauen aufzulauern und sie zu belästigen
die Opfer können glücklicherweise
fliehen bevor noch Schlimmeres geschieht
1946 siedelt er mit seiner Frau und
seiner kleinen Tochter nach Zorge im
Südharz um Sorge liegt in der britischen
Besatzungszone nahe der Grenze zur
sowjetischen schon damals lange vor
Todesstreifen und selbstschutzanlagen
eine sehr gefährliche Grenze der
Übertritt zwischen der sowjetischen und
den westlichen Besatzungszonen ist nur
mit speziellem Pass gestartet und
ansonsten strengstens verboten
sowjetische Soldaten patroullieren
entlang der Grenze und verhaften wen sie
ohne Pass antreffen es gibt Schmuggel
auch Menschen Schmuggel und brutale
Gewalt
viele Grenzgänger und besonders viele
grenzgängerinnen werden überfallen
ausgeplündert manchmal vergewaltigt
manchmal ermordet Bruder Fleisch der
schon als Neunjähriger grenzschmuggel
betrieben hat wir erinnern uns an die
Schokolade er sieht in dieser Situation
seine Chance er erkundet die Grenze und
findet Schleich Pferde und verstecke er
schmuggelt Nudeln Fische Kämme und
Menschen
sozusagen als Führer der ihnen gegen
Geld einen sicheren Weg über die Grenze
verspricht für manche wird es der Weg in
den Tod seinen ersten Mord oder den
ersten für den er mit Sicherheit
verantwortlich gemacht werden kann
begeht er am 19 juli 1946 im Wald
zwischen den Örtchen Walkenried und
Ellrich schlägt er eine etwa 25-jährige
Frau mit einem Hammer und vergeht sich
dann an seinem schwer verletzten oder
vielleicht schon toten Opfer Rudolf
Pleil wird Der Totmacher
[Musik]
und er ist nicht allein viele seiner
Morde begeht er mit zwei Kumpanen Carl
Hoffmann und Konrad Schüssler
gutaussehende Vertrauen erweckende
Männer im Gegensatz zu ihm dem
untersetzten Mann mit dem runden Kopf
der von vielen Zeitzeugen als sehr
unsympathisch beschrieben wird das kann
ich verstehen es gibt nämlich eine Menge
Fotos von ihm und auf beinahe allen von
ihnen sieht man ihn lächeln auch auf
denen aus dem Gerichtssaal in dem ihm
schließlich der Prozess wegen Mordes an
zehn Frauen gemacht wird musst du dir
mal vorstellen okay aber klar wenn man
weiß was er getan hat interpretiert man
natürlich umso mehr rein in so ein Bild
aber ganz ehrlich ich kann auch alle
verstehen die ihn von Anfang an
unsympathisch fanden die gut aussehenden
Komplizen helfen sicher wenn es darum
geht dass Vertrauen von Frauen zu
gewinnen die Hilfe beim Überqueren der
Zonengrenze suchen
aber was sich daran auch noch krass
finde bei Männern die töten um ihre
perverse Lust zu befriedigen da geht man
doch normalerweise eher von Einzeltätern
aus was ist das denn für ein Irrsinn
dass ich da drei Leute für sowas
zusammenfinden ja da hast du recht
eigentlich eher ungewöhnlich dass ich
für diese Gewalttaten mehrere Täter
zusammenschließen aber vermutlich ist
das auch der damaligen Zeit geschuldet
denn der Zweite Weltkrieg war gerade zu
Ende und viele Menschen haben jahrelang
unfassbare Grausamkeiten gesehen und
viele Männer waren an diesem Groll Taten
beteiligt was zählte schon ein
Menschenleben im Zweiten Weltkrieg und
überhaupt in der Nazi Zeit mit ihrem
Terror und ihrer unmenschlichen
Ideologie die Menschen sind
traumatisiert verstört zerstört jeder
menschliche Abgrund der normalerweise
versteckt und unterdrückte ist wird
durch die Umstände der Zeit wieder weit
aufgerissen und dennoch die meisten
finden irgendwann in den Alltag zurück
funktionieren
irgendwie wieder aber für manche da gibt
es kein Zurück Mirko du hast da noch ein
Zitat mitgebracht vielleicht passt das
jetzt ja an dieser Stelle ganz gut na
klar das stammt von dr med Fritz
Barnstorf der Pleil nach seiner
Verhaftung ausgiebig psychologisch
untersucht und darüber 1950 im Spiegel
geschrieben hat vom Stahlbad des Krieges
ist bei diesem Trieb Menschen nichts
anderes als eine Verhärtung seiner
antisozialen Instinkte zu erwarten seine
sexuellen Erfahrungen mit hafendirnen
werden ihm fast wieder Willen
beigebracht er blamiert sich dabei und
von dieser Verletzung seiner männlichen
Geltungssucht rührt seine in allen
mordgeständnissen später durch klingende
Wut in seinen geschlechtlichen
Leistungen nicht für voll anerkannt zu
werden
es rührt daher teilweise auch sein Hass
auf die Frauen die er am liebsten alle
ausrotten möchte
Pfeil wird ein willenloses geschöpftes
Krieges dessen Schrecknisse ihn in
seiner gefühlsstumpfheit zwar nicht
erschüttern dessen lebensverachtende
Hoheit ihn aber zu seiner eigentlichen
Natur hereinreifen lässt die Geschichten
seiner Mittäter die kennen wir nicht
ganz so gut aber auch sie wird der Krieg
ganz sicher geprägt haben und auch in
ihnen hat er wohl Abgründe aufgerissen
die sonst vielleicht gut verborgen
geblieben werden die Nachkriegszeit ist
natürlich auch eine Zeit in der es keine
funktionierende staatliche Ordnung gibt
eine Zeit totaler Unsicherheit ich denke
schon dass das auch dazu beigetragen hat
dass ich da eine regelrechte Bande von
frauenmördern zusammenfindet ja und dass
sie so lange unbehellig Trauben
vergewaltigen und morden kann die
Geschichte ist bis hierhin schon
unglaublich dabei liegen Pleil und seine
blutlustigen Kumpane gerade erst los
die Liste der Taten und das wirklich
ihre Nachspiel in der Justiz sind so
umfänglich dass wir euch den todmacher
in zwei Teilen erzählen und hier endet
der erste so viel kann ich euch schon
mal verraten am Ende verhilft Blei der
Gerechtigkeit sich durchzusetzen auch
wenn er das sicher ganz anders gemeint
hat aber dazu morgen mehr danke dass ihr
bei Teil 1 dabei wart ich bin Toni und
ich bin Mirko und wir hören uns wieder
bei Teil 2 Redaktion Stefan Netze Band
Script und Postproduktion